att trpe depuis 3 mois c'est le balai
des Benes à ordure le long de la
National 10 un samedi sur de l'ancien
parking de la Poste se métamorphose en
déchetterie végéaux tout venant gravas
et déchets électroniques tout y passe
depuis que la ville s'est retirée de la
gestion commune de celle de
trappéenc je préférais l'ancienne mais
on fait avec ce qu'on a pourquoi ah
parce que c'était plus près de chez moi
tout
simplement et pourtant la déchetterie
éphémère se trouve désormais en plein
cœur de la ville ce bricoleur vient pour
la troisième fois toujours pour la même
raison
ah je suis venu amener de la terre que
j'avais en trop et ça fait mon 4è voyage
depuis ce matin est-ce que c'est
pratique cette nouvelle bégéterie plus
ou moins plus ou moins parce que bon
bien bien souvent on fait la pas mal de
queue et puis des fois les ben sont un
peu route pour pour pouvoir décharger
quoi il reviendra dans 15 jours car il
lui reste encore qure remorques de terre
une petite révolution pour les trapistes
une habitude pour la société
gestionnaire des déchets c'est le même
principe pour toutes les autres déchet
si ce'est qu'effectivement d'abord il
faut trouver un lieu qui soit à peu près
adéquat qui permette ces manipulations
de Ben qui sont je dirais le lot commun
chez nous mais qui qui pour lequel il
faut pas mettre en danger les habitants
et les utilisateurs environ 90 personnes
utilisent ce nouveau principe de
déchetterie mobile en une journée un
concept qui est pour l'instant à laisser
mais qui pourrait peut-être devenir
pérenne avec quelques aménagements dans
les mois à venir elle représente pour la
mairie une économie de près de 2 tiers
sur les 250000 € du précédent budget
alloué à la déchetterie
[Musique]
classique